joe signed to himself quietly looking
out of the window at the still silent
stretch of highway snaking through the
desert only to disappear somewhere over
the horizon the sun was slowly crawling
down almost completely vanished from
sight and he knew when it was gone
there'd be no light left in the desert
it wasn't the same kind of darkness you
found in the city there they had street
lights and cars whizzing through with
their headlights on full blast it never
really got dark in the cities but out
here
nothing but true pitch-black darkness
for miles around only alleviated when
the sky was clear enough for the stars
to shine through or broken by the beams
of a passing car speeding down the
highway giving another side joe sipped
on his coffee by this point it was
lukewarm to match the dropping
temperature outside and bitter to the
taste but he needed the caffeine to keep
himself awake after all he had a long
night ahead of him but then again they
were all long nights in this line of
work this was the only diner from miles
around and he had no idea just how many
hours it would be before he next got to
eat or drink anything with an almost
empty pot with the last drags of coffee
in one hand the waitress came up to joe
at his table it was the last spot in the
diner with anyone still sitting in it
closing time she told him with a tired
smile one for the road nodding joe
lifted his travel mug for her to fill as
her work day was ending his was about to
start he grabbed his jacket and slung it
over his shoulder leaving a few dollars
as a tip on the table before he made his
way out of the diner and over to his car
buckling into the driver's seat joe took
a deep breath as he pulled his phone out
of his pocket dreading the potential
barrage of notifications that would come
flooding through the second he did
opening up the corresponding app he
clocked in for the night and sure enough
was instantly met with a veritable tidal
wave of requests grumbling quietly to
himself he tapped accept on the first
one he saw and turned the key in the
ignition working as a driver for a
carpool and ride sharing service was far
from a simple job at the best of times
but even more so in this particular area
of the southwestern united states the
state of new mexico shared a border not
only with texas but with chihuahua one
of the northernmost states of mexico
being so close to the border meant that
most of the calls and requests for lifts
that joe received on an average night
meant he needed to bounce back and forth
between the u.s and mexico crossing the
border at his clients request legally of
course we're not going all breaking bad
here today some nights weren't so
complicated someone might just need a
quick ride from dona ana to the town of
truth or consequences a new mexico town
named after we kid you not a tv game
show sure that might have been a 75 mile
drive up the i-25 but at least it didn't
involve crossing from el paso into the
city of juarez at this time of night it
was nowhere near as busy as during the
day but even so that didn't make hopping
back and forth over the border and all
the red tape it entailed any less of an
arduous process especially stuck behind
the wheel of a car for hours on end
tonight however wasn't a simple night
joe's first call was for a pickup from a
couple whose flight had been rerouted to
the international airport in juarez they
seemed to be newlyweds and demanded to
be taken all the way back to a hotel in
las cruces making it abundantly clear
that they didn't want to stay closer to
the airport and outright refusing when
joe offered to recommend them some
nearby hotels getting to know most of
the area around the three-way
intersection between new mexico texas
and the mexican border after driving
around it so many times he'd gotten to
know the area pretty well unfortunately
not everyone wanted to hear a display of
joe's local knowledge most of them just
wanted him to drive them in silence next
up a group of rowdy guys real frat house
types from the university of el paso
texas they wanted to be taken to a bar
halfway across the city a bit more of a
straightforward trip joe thought
although he could have done without them
drunkenly chanting spring break at the
top of their lungs every five minutes
after that it was another jaunt across
the border this time transporting a suit
and stenson wearing texas gentleman to
horizon city he spent the whole ride on
his phone talking at length about a
business deal he just closed not saying
a word to joe the entire time doug
dimmidome eat your heart out the next
person to request a lift wasn't much
more talkative either she was a
20-something girl who plainly stated she
just wanted to get far away from sierra
blanca hours and hours had ticked by
since joe had left the diner the last of
the coffee and his travel mug have been
finished long before his next ride
request had come through and required
him to once again make the drive out to
the other side of the border by this
point the evening had turned into night
and was now approaching the earliest
hours of the following morning the
desert still filled with nothing but
deep inky blackness the same desert that
had scorched acres upon acres of skin
that had taken so many lives big and
small and had picked the skin and flesh
from countless bones the desert can be a
truly merciless place at the best of
times but sometimes there's a little
something more out there just waiting
for you dark and hungry occasionally as
he drove back towards el paso joe would
see another car speeding towards him on
the other side of the highway but it was
so dark that he could see nothing of the
driver only their headlights were
visible right up until they drove past
him everything behind the hood of the
oncoming car almost imperceptible as it
whizzed through the night crossing the
border so many times a night joe had
become friendly with a few of the
officers that patrolled the gates waving
cars pass after they'd shown the
necessary paperwork he was never usually
held there for long enough to start
actual conversations with them
exchanging only a friendly nod or
one-liner with the few border patrol
guards whose names he could still
remember but sometimes when things were
a little quieter at the gates he'd
overhear the odd passing comment while
his driver's side window was rolled down
tonight as the long barrier in front of
his car was raised joe caught a few
words coming through on a radio
belonging to one of the guards something
vague about sightings of phantom lights
he chuckled to himself writing it off as
yet another alleged alien sighting
something about the desert at night
really seemed to capture people's
imaginations joe thought to himself as
he pulled away from the border gate
heading for the i-10 there were always
stories like that circulating around
this area of new mexico it was easy to
see why being so close to roswell new
mexico the home of alien sightings and
just a couple hundred miles away from
the true alien mecca area 51 a united
states air force base that secretly
housed alien life forms and spaceships
allegedly at least if years of
conspiracy believers and facebook
members are to be believed every so
often one of joe's passengers would ask
him about unidentified flying objects or
he'd overhear them talking amongst
themselves about a slew of urban legends
phantom hitchhikers that would hitch
rides on the highway only to vanish from
the back seats of cars and of course
tales of disembodied floating lights
either hovering way up in the sky or
just above the ground regardless of
whichever one was popular at any given
moment joe knew there were plenty of
weird and spooky stories coming out of
the desert what he was unaware of
however was that he was currently in one
of his own he'd been so wrapped up in
thoughts of what he might do if one of
the people that hired him turned out to
be a wandering spirit that joe didn't
even notice he had made a wrong turn it
was only by the virtue of glancing at
his car's gps that he even realized and
by then it had been long enough since
that he was completely unsure how far
back it was that he had made such an
error according to the map he was
nowhere he hadn't stopped his car was
still moving at a steady speed down the
long stretch of asphalt but the gps
didn't show any road at his current
location he had no clue which part of
which highway he was even on short on
options and short on time to get to his
next client for the night joe just did
what his job required of him he kept on
driving anyone watching from a distance
would have seen an empty lengthy portion
of highway with but one single car
traveling along it only the headlights
both illuminating the road in front of
it and giving away the car's position
slowing down slightly just to play it
safe joe tried searching up where he was
using the maps app on his phone he
figured he wouldn't get stopped for
checking his phone while driving or be
much risk to any other drivers on the
road after all it seemed like his was
the only car around for miles even if he
was still heading in near enough the
right direction for his next pickup that
would be at least some saving grace
maybe the map on the car's built-in gps
was a little outdated he thought and
that was preventing this part of the
highway from showing up connection to
the internet was extremely limited this
far out in the new mexico desert and by
the time the map loaded it didn't
provide much in the way of new
information or even the slightest bit of
comforting reassurance it only seemed to
agree with the gps that joe was well and
truly lost as he took his free hand off
the wheel for a split second just to try
and zoom in on the satellite view of the
terrain two bright white lights appeared
in the distance startled joe dropped his
phone into the front passenger seat
hearing it slip onto the floor of the
car as he gripped the steering wheel
again both hens back to 10 and 2. the
lights were speeding in the opposite
direction he was driving in a fair few
feet ahead of him but still it was
another vehicle on this otherwise empty
isolated stretch of the highway a loud
and sudden idea rang out in joe's head
if he could signal what he had assumed
to be another approaching car he could
ask the driver where exactly he was and
what the quickest route to get back to
the i-10 was he couldn't guarantee he
would make the oncoming vehicle stop and
help him after all so few people would
willingly trust a stranger on the
highway but considering his only other
options were to either keep driving
along this seemingly endless road or to
turn back around and try to find
wherever it was he'd made the wrong turn
in the first place needless to say joe's
hands were a little tied tapping the
appropriate switch affixed to his wheel
he flicked on his own headlights on and
off in an effort to catch the other
driver's attention nothing the pair of
headlights kept their current course
both theirs and joe's traveling parallel
to each other as if they were about to
joust with their beams of light hitting
the switch again joe tried lowering his
headlight setting and then raising them
back to full brightness still nothing
from the other driver he pushed the
emergency button that activated both the
front and rear lights of the car but
this one only yielded the same result
deciding there was nothing else that he
could do joe gently pulled his vehicle
over parking abruptly at this side of
the highway he instinctively checked his
rear view only to remember that there
wasn't anyone behind him just him and
the apparently oblivious driver
approaching ahead in a last-ditch effort
to get their attention joe punched the
car horn rolling down his window in
order to listen for a response the
blaring noise echoed through the empty
desert night a loud and sustained blast
followed by a beat of silence as joe
paused waiting to hear the same sound
back from the oncoming vehicle he
squinted at it through the dark it was
still pretty far but closing rapidly or
as far as he could tell it was all he
had to go on was the advancing lights
with nothing visible behind them joe
leaned out of his window hoping that it
would somehow give him better visibility
through the sheer darkness of a desert
at night it did as little to improve
things as a second much longer blast of
his horn did the other driver still
didn't react by now the lights were
close enough that whoever was behind the
other wheel would be able to see joe and
yet they didn't do anything to change
their speed didn't flicker their lights
back or sound their own horn nothing
just the same two points of light they
might as well have been floating just
above the ground given how they obscured
what was behind them at this point joe
was certain they were close enough to
see him now little more than a few feet
in front of his stationary car and still
closing at a sustained speed getting
agitated he went to hit his horn a third
time when he noticed something or rather
he noticed something that he hadn't this
car hurtling towards him through the
night wasn't making any sound it wasn't
just that the other driver deliberately
hadn't returned the signals joe had been
trying to give there was no noise coming
from it whatsoever no grumbling of an
engine nor the rolling of rubber tires
against the asphalt surface of the
highway it was silent just the pair of
ominous lights soundlessly racing
through the night heading straight for
where joe was sat parked still a sitting
duck like he was defenseless prey
violently turning the key in the
ignition joe slammed his foot down on
the accelerator his car sputtered to
life and careened on the road he was
headed straight for the other car if it
even was a car hoping to shoot straight
past it and take his chances continuing
along the highway alone the lights were
almost on top of him now still too
bright to make out anything behind them
but there was still no engine noise
nothing to indicate what the hell it
even was until one of them jumped onto
the hood of his car an orb of light
attached to a thrashing shape beneath
parted from the other it leaped through
the air and came down right in the path
of joe's car just as he was about to
pass what he first thought to be another
car the light smashed directly through
the windshield joe instinctively lifting
an arm to cover his face and protect his
eyes from the impending shower of broken
glass but it was in that second that he
took his eyes off the road that the
other light made its move it had been
perfectly parallel with joe's car only
to turn sharply and violently connecting
with the driver's side door with enough
force to not only dent the metal surface
but to completely lift the car up it
barreled sideways tumbling over itself
off the highway and into the surrounding
desert trapped inside buckled tight joe
was thrown about in his seat unable to
study himself as the car rolled his arm
was still over his face splinters of
glass showering over him the
whatever it was was still thrashing
about its glow illuminating the entire
interior of the car until the whole
vehicle came to a stop landing upside
down wheels in the air pointing up at
the cloudy night sky hanging the wrong
way up joe reached for his seat belt and
unclasped it his head instantly dropped
onto the ceiling of the upturned car
through the shattered driver's side
window he crawled out on his hands the
pain was shooting through his whole body
bruises and blood covering his arms an
intense agonizing feeling of broken
bones on top of that rolling over onto
his back joe looked up at the wreck of
his car his livelihood and the monster
standing in front of it illuminated
fully for the first time by the car's
still active headlights the thing had
managed to pull itself free from the
destroyed windshield and was now pacing
slowly around the overturned hood it
walked on two legs but it didn't move
like a man in fact it didn't even look
like one it was like something pulled
straight out of prehistoric times a pair
of hinged limbs supporting a streamlined
reptilian body with hooked claws on its
feet its back was arched keeping itself
low as its two arms stayed close to its
center the creature had almost
human-like hands but each finger was
tipped with long pointed talons but its
head was what joe saw first what he had
seen at a distance and mistaken for car
headlights only a few minutes ago in the
place he wouldn't have expected to see a
pair of slitted eyes staring at him was
a bulbous mass of a head bioluminescent
light glowed from beneath the monster's
skin a brain visible amongst a web of
bright organs and beneath that a wide
gaping maw of sharp teeth joe noticed
another light drawing mirror brightening
the area where he lay defenseless the
second of the raptor-like monsters was
pacing closer to him both her glowing
heads kept low to the ground ready to
strike
yep looks pretty clear to me one of the
men disguised as a highway patrol
officer announced handprints mad job
with what their front paws look like no
trace of the driver just a big wreck in
the middle of nowhere i better get on
the horn to control then his colleague
replied wearing a similar uniform i
thought scp-745s were only found a
little north of here oh we shut off this
section of the highway they usually show
up at the first foundation agent
explained casually sipping his coffee as
he looked at the upturned wreckage of
joe's car his body was nowhere to be
found but every now and then a couple of
them will show up a bit away from there
one of them wouldn't come this far into
the south of new mexico on its own
though ah because of the lights right
his fellow agent responded the two of
them walking back towards the car
their heads they mimic car headlights or
something well there's that the first
man nodded taking one last look at the
long open desert around them and the
highway stretching through it plus it
must get lonely traveling out here on
your own now go and check out
scp-1265 the mesozoic preserve and
scp-682 terrifying test logs to continue
on a jurassic journey filled with more
rampaging reptilian creatures and other
ravenous raptor-like anomalies